welcome back we we just finished this
problem with the pulleys and the
inclined plane and I just wanted to do
one final thing on this problem just
because I think it's it's interesting
and then we can move on to what seems
like a pretty fun problem so the last
thing I want to figure out is we figured
out this 20k look actually the whole
system will accelerate up and to the
right at 4.1 3 meters per second squared
and the second part of this question is
what is the tension what is the tension
in this rope or this wire and at first
you might say oh this is complicated you
know this thing isn't static anymore the
thing is actually accelerating how do I
do it well this is how you think about
it just just pick one part of the system
look at let's say that all we could see
was this 20 kilogram mass right so let's
say all we could see was this 20 20
kilogram mass and we know it's suspended
from a wire and we also know that this
20 kilogram mass is not it's not
accelerating as fast as it would if the
wire wasn't there it's accelerating only
at 4.13 meters per second if the wire
wasn't there it'd be accelerating at 9.8
meters per second just acceleration of
gravity so the wire must be exerting
some upward force on the object and that
is the force of tension that is what's
slowing that's what's moderating its
acceleration from being 9.8 meters per
second squared to being 4.13 meters per
second squared so essentially what is
the net force on this object on just
this object well the net force is and
you could ignore what I said before
about the net force all in the different
in all the other places but we know that
the object so we know that the object is
accelerating downwards well we know it's
20 kilograms so that's this mass and we
know that it's accelerating downwards at
4.13 meters per second squared so the
net force 20 times c times 20 is 80 -
let's just say 83 Newtons 83 Newtons
down we know that the net force is 83
Newtons down we also know that the
tension force
the tension force plus the force of
gravity and what's the force of gravity
the force of gravity is just the weight
of the object so the force of tension
which goes up plus the weight of gravity
the force of gravity is equal to the net
force and the way I set this up tension
is going to be a negative number just
because I'm saying positive numbers are
downwards so a negative number would be
upwards so tension will be what is 80
what is 83 divided - 89 196 e minus 196
is equal to minus 113 Newtons and the
only reason why I got a negative number
is because I used positive numbers for
downwards so minus 113 Newton's
downwards which is the same thing as 113
Newton's upwards and so that is the
tension in the rope and you could have
done the same thing on this side of the
problem all that would have been well
yeah you could have done the exact same
thing on this side of the problem you
would have said well what would have it
accelerated naturally if there wasn't
some force of tension on this rope going
backwards and then you're saying oh well
we know it would have gone in this
direction at some acceleration but it's
going in the other direction so you use
that you figure out the net force and
then you say the tension plus all of
these forces have to equal the net force
and then you should solve for the
tension and it would be the same tension
now we will do a fun and somewhat simple
then maybe maybe a instructive problem
so I have a PI this is the PI this is
the PI this is parallel lizzy and I have
my hand you can tell that my destiny was
really to be a great artist this is my
hand and I'm holding a pie and I'm
looking to to smash this pie into into
this this individuals face
I actually was a how was my the
newspaper cartoonist in high school so I
have some minor anyway let's make it a
bald man well anyway I shouldn't be
focusing on the drawing and let's make
him on let's have see isn't mustache
anyway I am looking to throw this pie
into this guy's face and the problem is
is I need to figure out how fast do I
need to accelerate this pie for it to
not fall down right because what's
happening well there's the force of
gravity on this pie there's a force of
gravity on this pie and if I don't
accelerate it fast enough it's just
going to slide down and I'll never be
able to it'll never reach the guy's face
so I don't want this pie to slide down
at all how far faster have to push on it
well we know that the coefficient of
friction we you don't know this but I
know that the coefficient of friction
between my hand and the pie the
coefficient of friction is equal to 0.8
so given that how fast do I have to
accelerate it well let's see what has
what is happening so we have the force
of gravity pulling down so let's say
that the the mass of the pies is M M
equals mass so what is the force of
gravity pulling down on the pie well the
force of gravity is just equal to M
times 9.8 right the force of gravity is
equal to M times 9.8 in order for this
pie to not move down what what what what
do we know about the net forces on that
pie well we know that the net force is
on that pie have to be 0 so what would
be the offsetting force well would be
the force of friction so we would have a
force of friction acting upwards right
because the force of friction always
acts opposite to the direction that the
thing would move otherwise so
essentially our force of friction our
force of friction has to be greater than
roughly greater than or equal to because
if it's greater than it's not like the
pie is going to move up friction by
itself will never move something it'll
just keep something from being moved
let's just figure out the minimum I want
to do the whole inequalities the force
of friction has to be equal similarly to
9.8 times the mass of the pie so if the
if the coefficient of friction is 0.8
what is the force that that I have to
apply well the force have to apply in
this case is going to be the normal
force right that's normal to the to the
bottom of the pie right I am like the my
hand is now like the surface of the ramp
so this is the normal force and we know
that the force of friction is equal to
the coefficient of friction times the
normal force I'm going to switch colors
because this is getting monotonous
so and the force of friction we know has
to be nine point eight times the mass so
nine point eight meters per second times
the mass nine point eight M is the force
of friction and that has to equal the
coefficient of friction times the normal
force remember the normal force is
essentially the force that I'm pushing
the pie with and we know this is 0.8 so
we have nine point eight times the mass
that's not meters that's the mass is
equal to 0.8 times the normal force and
then so you have the normal force is
equal to nine point eight times the mass
divided by 0.8 what's nine point eight
divided by 0.8 nine point eight divided
by 0.8 is equal to twelve point two five
so the the normal force that I have to
apply is 12.25 times the mass so that's
the force I am applying is times the
mass we don't know the mass of the pie
so how fast am I accelerating the pie
well force is equal to mass times
acceleration this is the force 12.25 M
that's the force is equal to the mass
times the acceleration of the pie right
and it's the same pie that we're dealing
with all types of still m and you can
take out M from both sides of the
equation so the acceleration the the
rate at which I have to change the
velocity or the acceleration the
have to apply to the PI is 12.25 12.25
meters per second squared and so
actually I have to apply more than one G
right because a G is is the force of
gravity I have an N gravity accelerate
something at 9.8 second a 9.8 meters per
second squared so I have to do something
at 12 I have to push and accelerate the
PI at 12 point to 5 meters per second
squared so it's something a little over
1 g in order for that pi to not fall and
in order for my normal force to provide
a force of friction so that the PI can
reach this bald man's face I will see
you in the next video